quand est-ce que vous estimez votre date
de péremption à vos fous
quand même
moi je suis juste je vais vous dire je
suis surtout là pour que vous puissiez
joindre les deux bouts voilà mais c'est
vrai voilà non non non non moi
franchement j'ai une date dans ma tête
et un successeur j'ai une date dans ma
tête non un successeur
j'ai une date dans ma tête c'est sûr et
vous savez ce que vous ferez après bien
sûr
mais toujours dans la production t'as
fait que géralis j'étais top
en français ou pas
donc après j'ai arrêté de quoi
on fera des choses vous inquiétez pas
j'ai pas dit que c'était demain mais
j'ai la date dans la tête je lui
donnerai ultérieurement
Daniel tu seras encore là t'inquiète pas
et toi toi tu me regardes comme si tu
avais envie de prendre ma place
[Applaudissements]
tu es malade ou quoi quoi mais là mais à
pied tour là il me dit demain tu prends
la place de Cyril
mais il nous dit ça demain il me dit ça
demain arrête il me dit ça demain j'y
suis là
je te dis ça demain
je te promets que c'est vrai